he tells me that he did not take this
picture and he's not standing I I know
probably about as much this picture as I
do about any of the talk I'll present I
like it looks like a hierarchy the
constants are astronomical so i can say
so i want to begin by by telling you a
theorem the promise he was very
important theorem it's a little bit a
little bit technical but I promise it's
worth it to know it theorem concerns a
matrix of positive real numbers and and
it places a condition of the number of
good set we say a set is Delta good if
there's exists a function that satisfies
this inequality and then there's a
certain limit relation we can say about
about about f this function f of k delta
which counts the largest such such Delta
good set I know it's maybe it's hard to
get some intuition for it has anyone
seen this before or have some intuition
for what this is about um I can I can
also rephrase it in some some different
language that that might be more
familiar with proven in 1949 by Shannon
and that is the noisy channel capacity
theorem says that the capacity of a
noisy channel to transmit information is
the maximum / input distributions of the
mutual information between the input and
the output and this equation this did
not use any jargon right which is set
and inequalities it's combinatorial it's
elementary it's clear it's precise and
this is full of jargon so all of these
words their definitions which are not on
the slide if you haven't seen them
before you would have no idea what you
know what it was referring to but once
you have the benefit of the jargon it
really becomes I think you'll agree a
much nicer statement and something
that's much more amenable to proving
further statements and kind of
understanding what's going on and it's
this sort of a parable I hope for what I
will tell
which is in computer science and math we
often want to consider tensors with many
indices that are full of real numbers or
complex numbers and we want to estimate
properties of these things norms or
functions or things that we're
optimizing and it can get pretty
abstract and pretty hairy and when we
have tensors of non-negative real
numbers that add up to 1 it's sometimes
useful to call them probability
distributions and to use concepts like
entropy and Markov chains and so on to
describe them and when they're complex
numbers or even real numbers are
sometimes negative a quantum information
can sometimes be a productive metaphor
for thinking about them and in this case
I think it's just one of many metaphors
that can be used but i will show you
some cases where where it is a useful
one and they give you a sense of of the
problems that it's useful for i'll start
with the problem that really does not
look at all quantum mechanical that
looks really just sort of like a basic
math problem with some that you could
even not even computer science is
apparent in that in this problem and
this takes calculated a norm of a matrix
so the norm I'm becomes interested in is
the 224 norm so let's define what I mean
by the 224 norm we'll just find the P
norm of a matrix to be the expectation
of the peace power of the entries all
raised to the 1 over P power so the two
norm is the usual Euclidean norm using
the expectation for over the entries
rather than the sum the Infinity norm
would be the largest entry the one nor
would be the average of the entry and
the four norm you can think of it as
like the two norm but it weights that
heavier entries more so a bunch of small
entries contribute less than a single
large entry and the 224 norm is
measuring the operator norm of a matrix
so how much does a matrix how much can a
matrix blow up the norm of any vector
that acts on but it measures the input
in the two norm and the output in the
foreign or so the input is maximized
over unit vectors in the two norm and
the output is maximized so the output
you're measuring is in is in the four
norm okay so this is sort of a basic
norm of a matrix itches I'll tell you
later why we'd like to compute it but
it's even it's a pretty simple
mathematical object and we'd like to
know this is now the computer science
question how hard is it to calculate
this thing and one way it can be helpful
to think about is to take the fourth
power so now this is we're maximizing
over X expectation over the entries of
the output and then the ice entry the
output is this thing right here and so
we take it to the fourth power and then
when you expand that out just expand out
the the fourth power you can see that
you're summing over these j 1 through j
4 which are the entries of x times some
big thing that depends on j 1 through j
4 so this you can just think of as a
degree for polynomial on the entries of
x and so this is exactly equivalent to
an optimization problem over a degree
for polynomial now computing the 222
norm is easy because we can it's easy to
optimize over degree two polynomials but
degree 4 is in general NP hard to
optimize over so will not be able to
solve it exactly so now we say we ask
well how can we approximate it and one
way we a natural way to do this is using
a semi definite programming higher and
this is one of the leading ways of
solving this type of problem and how
does it how does it work so here on the
right hand side I've written again the
polynomial optimization problem except
what we'll do is instead of optimizing
over X we will not will replace our
search for x by a search for the moments
of X so imagine that we first replaced X
by a distribution over all vectors X so
that's blown it up to be an infinitely
larger problem but then we instead of
looking for all the information about
the distribution we only look at the low
order moments so the moments of degree
of decay of this distribution and so we
can encode these moments with a linear
map el that maps degree K polynomials
two real numbers and this L is like our
way of expressing an opinion about the
moments of the
distribution so L of one should be so
and this term up here means we maximize
it over over suitable L ones that could
actually correspond to real moments of a
distribution the expectation of this
polynomial which means the sum over the
coefficients of the expectation of this
monomial here this is it's a little
technical so please yell if there's
anything confusing and and stop me so
what are the so I said that L should
satisfy the constraints that a real
distribution would satisfy that's not
completely true because that would take
too much computational efforts so it'll
just satisfy some of the constraints and
will only try and do the constraints
that we can based on looking at
polynomials up to degree K so L of one
should be one the that's like saying the
expectation of one should be one and
then we should impose the constraint
that X is a unit vector so the
expectation over I of X i squared should
equal one so that means that if you take
the expectation of that we apply L to
that then you should get zero and that
should still be true if you multiply by
any other polynomial and the other
condition is that if you have a for any
polynomial its square should have
positive expectation and again we can
only check this up to degree case if we
can only check it if this P has degree
at most K over 2 yeah oh ok so there to
this expectation over I means sum from I
equals 1 to N and then divided by n
whereas L you could call L more of a
maybe I should call it a pseudo
expectation it's my opinion about the
moment even if it doesn't correspond to
a real distribution this is the two norm
squared and I just wrote it like that to
emphasize there's a polynomial but this
thing here is the 2 norm square good any
other questions
so initially we were optimizing with all
n dimensional vectors yes yes in the
internet solutions everyone sit up
actually yeah they would correspond ah
that's a great question they would
correspond to L let's say that the true
solution is X hat then this would
correspond to L X to the Alpha equals x
hat to the Alpha by which I mean exhale
one to the alpha one dr dot X hat n to
the alpha n so if this in other words
take X hat consider a distribution
that's just the point mass on X hat so X
hat X is always equal to X hat and then
ask what are the moments of it so what
is the what is the expectation value of
you know X 3 times X 5 well then it
would just be exactly X hat 3 X hat 5
that's right so then L of a polynomial
would be P of X hat so L would be the
evaluation map I guess that's a similar
thing L is the evaluation map at point
except so that shows actually this
important argument this says that this
is a relaxation so this is a less than
or equal to and that's because the
maximum includes these evaluation maps
and the evaluation maps satisfy all
these conditions but it includes a bunch
of other things too which is why it's
not an equality because this includes
moments that do not correspond to Val
distributions okay so this one thing
that's not obvious that this actually is
a convergent series of approximation so
if K goes to infinity this does
approach the right answer but of course
that statement tells you nothing about
how quickly it converges and the runtime
this is a semi definite program and the
run time will be polynomial the number
of variables how many variables are
there well that's a question of how many
degree K monomials there are which is on
the order of n to the K so the runtime
will be M to the order K so it's blowing
up exponentially with K as K increases
he gets better and better but you pay
more and more so we'd like to know how
quickly does it actually converge um one
thing which is maybe not so obvious is
that this is actually some indefinite
program so L is a you know this is just
a bunch of linear functions that's just
specified by a vector these first two
are linear constraints and the vector
the last one looks funny because it's a
is for potentially all polynomials peeve
of loan of degree but this has turned
out to be a semi definite constraint and
I'll show you why this is so if what if
the constraint is l of p of x squared is
positive or sorry now- whenever the
degree is small enough that this fits
inside our our program and if we write P
in this way so alpha is a is a multi
index of of powers so X to the Alpha
means this kind of thing x1 to the alpha
1 and so on then what is l of p of x
squared it's the sum over alpha beta of
these coefficients p alpha pi beta times
this opinion about the moment L of X to
the alpha plus beta and if we make these
things into a matrix then demanding that
this be non-negative is precisely asking
that this matrix B positive
semi-definite so we want to check this
for all possible p there's an infinite
number of them but that's exactly what
semi definite programming does it the
sort of infinite number of linear
inequalities that correspond to a matrix
being positive semi definite it can
check efficiently over over that large
set so okay so this this is actually an
sdp and and it can be solved
time n to the order k and so it's a good
algorithm as long as long as k don't
have to be too big so before you go too
much further i want to mention that the
224 norm is not a just an obscure
problem for math but it is relevant to
theoretical computer science as well so
to other more popular problems are the
unique games problem of which one
version is given system of linear
equations over a finite field determine
if they're mostly satisfiable or mostly
unsatisfiable you're given the promise
that you can either satisfy 99% of them
or no more than 1% you want to know
which is the case because there are
linear equations over a finite field
it's easy to check whether they're all
satisfiable or not that you can do with
the calculor mination but this 99
percent versus 1% problem appears to be
hard so that is a problem of unknown
complexity small set expansion is is a
related one which says then the North
the expansion of the set is given a set
here what fraction of edges that start
with in the set also leave that set and
the normally the expansion problem asks
you what is the least expanding set of
say no more than half the vertices and
the small set expansion problem asks
this four sets that are maybe at most
one percent or point 0 1 percent of the
vertices but it asks you again a very
crude question about their expansion it
says are they are all of these sets
overwhelmingly expanding say 99 percent
of their edges leave or is there a set
of such size that barely expands at all
that only one percent of his edges leave
so this huge gap means it sounds like
perhaps a needs your problem than some
other and be complete ones but we don't
know the complexity and it's been shown
that these two have nearly I mean
roughly equivalent complexity modulo
some variants and some assumptions but
their complexity is pretty close and
turns out that the 224 norm is a
slightly harder problem than small set
expansion it's uh not quite equivalent
but it's but it's pretty close in
complexity on
and to make that statement a little bit
more precise we have this this theorem
that if if g is the adjacency matrix of
a graph let's say normalize so it's a
random walk matrix and p lambda is the
projector on to the the top I ghen space
of of G then if the graph has good small
set expansion I'm sorry yeah because if
the graph has high small set expansion
then the two to four norm of this
projector should be small and
intuitively the reason for this is that
the four norm is if you take a bunch of
unit vectors in the two norm the form is
highest for the ones that are
concentrated and so this optimization
problem is like cheaters inequality it's
like the way that normal expansions
related to the second largest eigen
value but because of the four norm it
especially favors smaller sets that
expand and so this this change in the
norm to the four norm is is enough to to
change the problem from changing from
measuring expansion to measuring
expansion of small sets yeah yes uh
there's a lambda here in a lambda there
so piece of lambda is the projector on
to all eigenvectors with eigenvalue
lambda and up so it's the top to the top
eigen space the graph and so it's
basically we can ignore the low-lying
ones and we just focus on this on this
top eigen space and we ask does it
contain a vector with very large for
norm and if so it contains a very
concentrated vector
that's right yeah any that's right um
there's yeah it's you get slightly
different parameters but we don't see
any advantage there maybe advantage is
going to other ones but we received okay
so um okay so this is one problem which
i think is interesting to solve right
the tutor for Noren problem is it's a
basic math problem would like to know
how well this this hierarchy converges
it appears to have nothing to do with
quantum mechanics let me tell you a
different problem originating from
quantum mechanics which we would also
like to solve so just to refuel states
are quantum state is a unit vectors and
dimensions if you have two quantum
states then the way you combine them is
the same way you would combine two
independent probability distributions if
they're one of them is M dimensions the
other women is n then the joint state
has em n dimensions and the entries are
just the products of the entries of the
individual ones and the vectors you get
in this way are called product vectors
and they correspond to independent
states vectors you can't get in this way
or are called entangled and so entangled
vectors are those that cannot be written
this way and observable is anything we
observe about a quantum state is not a
linear function of the state it's a
quadratic function more precisely it's
with if its linear envy and linear in in
the conjugate of V and so it's
convenient instead to work with instead
of with v with VV star so we have
something that observables are linear in
these objects are called are called
density matrices and one type of density
matrix is VV star but if you take a
mixture of them if convex combination
then you get the most general form of
density matrix which is any matrix
that's positive semi definite and has
traced one so that this is what happens
when you take a quantum state
distribution over pure states can in
general be written is is a general
density matrix
and this form allows us to incorporate
both classical correlation and
entanglement or either any combination
of the two because here this sounds very
much analogous to correlation but it's
four states that we know perfectly it
doesn't allow for the fact that we might
have a distribution over see if you
might not know we have and so to see the
difference between correlative states in
this picture and entangled States one
example of a correlative state is the
state that can be a pair of qubits that
can be either 0 or 1 as either 00 or 11
or each with probability one-half and so
this is an example of a density matrix
with with classical correlations so with
one half probability both systems are in
state 0 and both system or with one half
property both systems are in state 1
versus an entangled state is
deterministically in this single you
know the system is in a known state and
that state is one that is entangled that
cannot be written as a tensor product of
of individual of states on the
individual systems and so you can see
from these examples that even should
defy entanglement is a little bit
slippery we can't just say that a
density matrix is entangled if you
cannot factorize it into one part for
one system in one part for another
because that was already true
classically that was already true for
probabilities we have to talk about what
does it mean to be have uniquely quantum
correlations ones that cannot be
explained by by probability
distributions and so the way we do that
just as in the pure case it's easier to
explain what's not entangled than what
is entangled so what's not entangled and
here for density matrices we caught we
use the term separable what's not
entangled means that your state can be
written as a convex combination of pure
product states so there's some with you
can think of it as you flip a coin with
a probability I one party gets state
visa by and the other party get state w
sub I and so the correlations that exist
are purely classical so here piece of I
is a probabilities mission and these v's
are and w's are unit vectors another way
to say that is that the separable states
are the convex
of everything with a form V V Star
tensor WWE star for four unit vectors V
and W and then finally I'm going to come
to the problem that we want to solve
people often prepare states in the lab
and want to say they've made
entanglement and so just a very basic
question which many many people would
like to solve is given a state row that
someone has perhaps prepared in the lab
and determined every with enough
measurement they've made it repeatedly
they've determined every entry of the of
the matrix give it a state row is it
entangled or more precisely given
there's either separable or far from
separable just to make the problem more
tractable determine which of these is
the case this is called the week
membership problem you can define it for
any convex set and this is for defining
for separable states a closely related
problem is that the opt is an
optimization problem so given a matrix M
which we can think of as a linear
function on on matrices maximize the
trace of M times row over this set of of
separable states neither for any convex
set these are kind of the two basic
questions you could ask membership in
the convex set or optimizing a linear
function over the convex set and you can
show not too difficult to show that
these are equivalent in difficulty so if
you can solve one you can solve the
other with more or less the same amount
of effort and they both appear to be
hard we don't really have have good ways
solve either question yeah just a bunch
of real numbers a complex numbers any
just written down if it as a just to
enough precision that you need to solve
the problem so you define the
optimization for so disappointed in
table of similar complexity for
they offer you any metric system
physically I this also comes up in
physics a good deal so there are many
situations where yes so one place this
would come up which is semi physical is
if you have you're going to perform my
correspond to a measurement operator and
trace it mrow let's say the measurement
operator outputs either accept or reject
and this might correspond to the
probability of accepting and so you want
to choose this separable state that has
the largest chance of being accepted by
this measurement and this corresponds to
this is not quite physics yet this
corresponds to quantum Merlin Arthur
proofs with two unentailed provers one
place where it comes up in physics is
when you have a system this is called
the mean field model where every
particle is interacting identically with
every other particle and you want to
find the lowest energy of that system
the ground state then you can show that
very hard that the solution to this is
always a separable state and so to
minimize the energy you want to minimize
not over general States but / /
separable states and so that's that's
another place this comes up and there
are many other problems to take a little
longer to describe where this also comes
a bit um this is actually a little nicer
to talk about so I think I'll more often
talk about optimization but they're
they're obviously pretty similar so one
way you can solve the problem is by
using some intuition from physics which
is the the principle of monogamy of
entanglement which is that if systems a
and B are entangled then systems a and C
cannot also be very entangled or at
least there's some trade-off between the
entertainment between those pairs and
this is for a system on a state on
systems a B and C and the one intuition
for why this should be true is that if
the system is very entangled I haven't
even proven this point here but it's
it's not so hard to show if it system is
very entangled then a measurement of B
will reduce the entropy of a and that's
even let even correlations will achieve
that just if they're correlated that
means that knowing something about be
will reduce the entropy of a and so that
means that a and C could not be very
entangled because that conditioning on
this measurement outcome we would get a
collection of steaks on AC with each one
with let's say very low entropy for for
Alice for system a which means that
there cannot be very much correlation
left over with with see sort of a fuzzy
proof but it turned out to be a valid
intuition and yeah that's right
yes so so one way in this is stronger is
I said that a B and AC cannot both be in
tank highly entangled but this actually
says if a B is highly entangled AC
cannot even be correlators so that's
true but there is there's not much
stronger version yeah yeah great yeah so
let's do an example which appears to be
everything is entangled with everything
so this state so this appears to be a
counter example because everything is
entangled is everything but let's look
at a be by itself the reduced state of a
B if i trace out system see the reduced
state of a B is this classical state
that's the state of a B and it's also
the state of AC so that is no one tangle
Minh tat all so that's so it turned out
to actually that's right that's right
yeah entanglement has there's a lot of
funny things about it I mean one of the
most basic funny things about it is that
a can be mixed a could have positive
entropy whereas a bee can be pure I have
zero and should we be in a known state
and similarly you know a beacon can be
mixed but ABC could be a collectively
entangled state um so uh good so I want
to I want to give sell the intuition you
know I was thinking about these proofs
from our computer science versus the
physics perspective and I think there's
something that in physics on-quarter
information we really take for granted
that might be less transparent from
computer science which is the key thing
at all of these is the partial trace so
when I went from this state to that
state I
did a partial trade threw away systems
feet and what is the partial trace well
it's the density matrix on ABC has sort
of three row indices and three column
indices corresponding to the system's a
B and C and the partial trace is to
basically apply the trace map to the
third index then you just sum over the
same sum over J for the same J plan to
the row and the column and so this is
mathematically how you get the system
for of a be from the state of ABC and
you can interpret this as measuring
system see in the basis that you that
you perform the tracing so what does it
mean to do that trace in some basis it
means you sum over the diagonal entries
of course the trace is the same at any
basis but different bases while
mathematically the same correspond to
different measurements every every
orthonormal basis is a measure it can
correspond to some quantum measurement
and different measurements will give us
different ensembles left over for system
a and B it'll always give the same
density matrix but it will let us
interpret it as a different convex
mixture of pure States and physically
people say that if you throw away a
system then you can you don't know what
happened to it it could have been
measured any which way you have no way
of distinguishing those ways that it's
measured and mathematically that
corresponds to the fact that the trace
looks the same at any basis and this is
actually if you're going to read this
literature you'll find this is actually
one of the key things behind all these
defend Eddie theorems and these proofs
of monogamy is that there's always a
clever choice of basis in which to throw
something away and I think it's sort of
unstated that this is sort of the
freedom that one of the things that you
learn from quantum mechanics which is so
basic and quantum mechanics you take it
for granted but i think is is maybe not
so appreciated outside of it that you
have to use this this this basis freedom
when when when reducing your system I'm
getting a little bit ahead of myself I
haven't explained why this is related
the sum of squares hierarchy from before
but I'll come back to that in a minute
okay so this is an argument this is an
intuition for how you can approximate
the set of separable states and if you
take this intuition and turn into an
algorithm you get actually a higher he
of approximations so the algorithm will
search for we could not require the
state be separable but we can require
that it be what's called k extendable
and that means it's a state on systems a
B and I require that there be an
extension to not think of it a stiff
system for Alice and Bob an extension to
take different Bob's such that each ABI
system look the same as the original
state and as I increase K that gets to
be a more and more stringent test if K
is one this is no requirement at all
every state is one extendable and then
as I increase K gets tougher and tougher
and it turns out that separable states
exactly equal the set of infinitely
extendable states that this is uh this
is a in the limited it's a perfectly
exact test of course the the runtime of
this search is increasing exponentially
because we have to search over all
states of this size even if you impose
some symmetry condition the size is
still growing exponentially with K and
of course we know it converges but we
don't know at what rate it converges if
we want to think of this as an algorithm
that sort of the crucial question which
is should be familiar i get from the
from the first part and if it of course
is not surprising that this out this
relaxation looks very similar to to the
semi definite program for the two to
four norm because they're essentially
they're essentially the same essentially
the same SDP framework so to show you
yeah
there's if some state is K extendable
yeah is there a how unique for those
sources of these how unique is the
extension yeah it is there an extension
where all these insane so yeah in
general it may not be very unique i
don't i'm not sure i know i think i
think usually it won't be very unique
but i don't know of anyone who's looked
hard at that and you can without loss of
generality assume that the bees are
symmetric that the state is symmetric
under commuting the bees and why is that
because if you take any extension and
you average over all permutations of the
bees it's still a valid extension and
that's in practice a nice thing to do
because it reduces your number of
degrees of freedom but i won't use that
for any for any cruise okay so so of
course it shouldn't surprise you that
these problems are are essentially
equivalent and why is that let's say the
matrix a i right in the following form a
sub I let a sub I be the rows of a and
so I can and he said I are the standard
basis so i can write the matrix a like
this then I claim these ponds are
roughly equivalent one direction is easy
which is that if i can compute if i can
optimize the percept that i can i can
compute the tutor for norm why is that
well it's because this the the for norm
to the fourth power is is a jury for
polynomial and i can also write it as
the trace of some matrix m that depends
on the input a time some row which looks
like a a separable density matrix and it
turns out that the 224 norm to the
fourth power is exactly the optimum over
separable states of this of this
quantity now you might say well for
separable states the two systems didn't
have to look the same also these are
complex and these are real and this was
a convex combination and this is just a
single one but it turns out all those
details
don't really affect this point you can
those are kind of boring details that
you can verify kind of like how on that
first slide when I showed Shannon's
noida coding theorem i didn't put in the
normalization but it was but it was
still true fixing that is a kin to
fixing the normalization on that first
slide so morally these are these are the
same the other direction is a little bit
harder which is suppose you have an
algorithm to solve it should a former
own problem and you want to solve H step
then we have an arbitrary m and we want
to simplify it to look like this form
where it's the same expectation over the
same one for each for each side this is
actually a little bit non-trivial and
you can do it using some quantum
techniques from this this paper of mine
with ashley moser an hour from a few
years ago I it's why it works is sort of
not very insightful but roughly I can
say that we have a wave of transforming
if you want to compute hcf 41 m you can
transform it to a similar m prime where
m prime might be simpler or have some
nice structure in some way and that
paper we give a number of ways of
translating between different choices of
em which for the purpose of quantum
Berlin Arthur proofs was useful and and
turns out to be useful in general for
analyzing H step it's I'm making it
sound boring I think it's actually
pretty interesting there's a lot of nice
structure related to to entanglement in
it it was take a long time to get into
and I think the nice illustration of
quantum ideas be able to say something
useful about about tensors because I
really do not know how to express the
proof in any sensible way without
phrasing in terms of entangled States
and am making measurements and things
like that the probably is a way to do it
but I don't how to do it and not have it
look like the first slide of this talk
so there's a there's a nice
quantification story would just take me
15 minutes so I so I won't do it yeah
guess I understand the norms and the
tensors and so on but what's not clear
to me from the quantum view point is
what's the input and how large is it and
you're running time was good so the
input for each step is the matrix m and
it's size is n to the fourth by n to the
fourth and there's a bunch of complex
numbers and Precision's had a big deal
ok so great so we have this equivalence
so that's kind of exciting that small
set expansion seems to be related to the
tutor for norm which is related to H
separuh bility and so when we started
working on this I and a few other people
had this vision of this sort of two-way
street you know this bridge between the
quantum topics via this math problem to
the the problems that theoretical kinder
science is thinking about and because we
have a lot of 2a reductions then we can
get algorithms going in one direction
hardness results going the other
direction and something which is I think
if all of the optimistic conjectures
worked out there was a hope of getting
Kwazii polynomial upper and lower bounds
for for unique games obviously if we
haven't done in it we haven't achieved
that but there's there are conjectures
that are not obviously false that that
would lead to it um so this is sort of
the dream and I would say what our
progress has looked like um is you know
the things partially fit like it's done
this either success nor failure as
evaluation so let me give you an example
suppose you want to show that small set
expansion is hard right this is a big
open problem show that it's NP heart
what do we know we know that to estimate
H set to constant accuracy is quazy
polynomial hard what does that mean it's
not as hard to solving let's save your
matrix I said n to the fourth let's just
say m is dimension n it's not as hard as
solving a three-set instance of length
Oh No meulen n it's as hard as solving
or so at least it's hard is solving a
three-set instance of length log squared
n so if you believe three-set takes
exponential time then this would take
time and to the law again so barely more
than polynomial is still a non trivial
thing if you could show it so we have a
reduction from two to four norm to
outside from H step to the two to four
norm so that's great that means we have
quasi polynomial hardness for the two
two for DeMar something that we did not
know before um but remember when I
related the two to four norm too small a
set expansion we were talking about the
true to form of a particular class of
matrices of these projectors on to the
top eigen spaces of graphs seemed like
this really kind of technical thing but
it appears to be a barrier we have
hardness for a 22 for norm of some
different projectors that come up via
these various quantum reductions these
don't appear to look the same as the top
I ghen spaces of graphs whether this is
a fundamental problem or just we got
stuck we don't know whether so whether
we it's debatable whether we're very
close to the solution or very far from
the solution if I guess what i want to
say uh and so this basically does not
achieve our goal of hardness for small
set expansion but achieve something that
I think is still nice and not trivial
which is hardness for the two to four
norm which was which was not known
before and I'll leave it to your
interpretation how you know how close
you feel this is on the other direction
we'd like to would like to get hardness
result sorry we have hardest piece we'd
let you get algorithms um and here you
know I don't give the impression that
quantum is the only way to think about
things I think that here we have the
luxury of really alternate ways of
looking at it some of the metaphors are
quantum in and some are not so one other
way to think about these hierarchies is
to use the duel so remember that the
primal is you have this map l that
satisfies various properties the dual
you can think of it as
some generalized a little bit instead of
maximizing just f of X is the polynomial
your maximizes yep so the harness was
under exponential time that's right
that's right that's right that's right
um yeah so it's if you want the
unconditional statement the constant
multiplicative approximation of two to
four norm if you could do that you could
solve a three-set instance of length log
squared that's the unconditional um so
the duel okay so one way of getting some
intuition for these hierarchies is to
look at the door I mean what is the
jewel say well you want to upper bound
you want to the primal you wanna
maximize f of X the dual if you want to
get a good upper bound for it so let's
lam to be the upper bound how are you
going to upper bound it well suppose you
could write an equation of this form
where P is some arbitrary polynomial and
Q sub I or a bunch of other arbitrary
polynomials you know I'm sorry that some
should be an expectation you know that
this term is 0 so this whole term is 0
and you know that this thing here is the
sum of squares of polynomials so that's
non-negative so if you can write such a
thing that would prove that f of X is
less than or equal to lambda and if you
could do this with degree not too high
even better and so you can interpret the
duel as try to prove that f of X is less
include lambda using only the the norm
constraint and the fact that sums of
squares of polynomials that's what this
sum of Q sub I squared is are always
non-negative and in the course of this
proof don't use polynomials are ever to
a large degree so these are called sum
of squares proofs for that for that
reason and it gives a nice
interpretation in terms of sort of like
computer-assisted proof of of how this
semi definite program works so one
example is one way you might want to
constrain v3 between zero and one is to
say z squared of X equal to Z so in
inequality involving polynomials so you
can think of this as you have the action
it is less equal to V you want to derive
that v is less than equal to 1 so how do
you do that well 1 minus Z this is just
algebra you can write it like this that
second term is a square so you know it's
not negative and this thing we already
assumed was not negative so using our
assumption plus the fact that squares of
polynomials are not negative you can
prove this new thing so a kind of a
simple proof it actually took us a
really long time to come up with it but
it's an example of what these ftp can
can do so something a little more
non-trivial let's go back to the 224
norm so one way that the true to form is
sometimes described is in terms of
something called hyper contractility
which never mind why it's called that
and here's what it means suppose F is a
function on n bits and bits drinks
mapping troupe and restraints two reels
and suppose that function is a
polynomial of degree at most D so I know
we've been throwing our polynomials in
various ways this means a polynomial of
those n bits okay so it's the sum of
terms each involving at most D bit then
the foreign warm of this function cannot
be too much bigger than the tune or so
naively the forum could be bigger by a
factor that goes like X that goes
exponentially in n but here the bound
has no internet it only depends on d the
degree of this this thing so you can
express this as a statement about a two
to four norm of an operator specifically
take piece of DP the operator that
projects on two polynomials of degree at
most D then instead this operator has to
the four norm that's at most this number
9 to the 950 over 4 so that is a
statement about two to four hundred
operator and how do you prove this
statement um well if you look at the
proof you do induction on n and koshi
Schwartz as you often do and in koshi
Schwartz
you prove that well at some point you
have to come up with an inequality
you're doing a bunch of algebraic
shuffling and then at some point there's
inequality and what is that inequality
well it looks kind of like Q of x
squared is greater than equal to 0 so
the only place and in quality is used is
is of this form and it turns out that
means that if you run the SDP on this on
this input it will give you an answer
that's no more than 9 to the D over 4 so
the insights that you got from that
proof the computer could also get from
the SDP which I think one cute thing
about this is you know a lot of jobs are
disappearing thanks to automation and
people in this room you know we probably
all feel very safe and yet we probably
also write papers where the main tool is
kosher Schwartz and so just saying
should be we should be a little nervous
so um so this okay so this says it SP
does a good job for the two to four norm
um this also i think i'm i'm running a
little low on time so maybe i will not
go to details about this this also
applies to two unique games and this is
also assess now a slightly old paper
that i was on um there are these unique
game instances that are that are
integrality yet meaning that the basic
stp does a bad job meaning that it gets
an answer that's very far from the true
answer and it turns out that if you go
to high enough constant degree it does a
good that the this higher level sdp will
do a good job why is that well if you
look at the soundness poop so the proof
that the the true solution of the
instance is small these proofs are long
complicated beefs they use more than
cosi Schwartz they use all kinds of
things but all their inequalities you
can rephrase of the form to of x squared
greater than equal to 0 and so the sdp
can more or less if not find the answer
it can do as good a job as our previous
proofs or nearly as good a job so just
to clarify what i mean by an intergal
recap here let's say the feasible sdp
solution is way up here and the absolute
actual solutions are down here and you
can prove for ingenuity gap you have to
be able to prove it that it's actually a
gap so that means we have a proof that
the upper bound actual solutions is is
way down here and what I'm saying is
that you can prove using the sum of
squares techniques an upper bound that's
pretty close to here as well maybe equal
maybe a little bit higher but you know
far away from these things that we
previously new and kind of if I can make
the font smaller these would look a lot
closer you know pretty close to the
droid believe the actual solutions are
so this is a way of showing that these
things can can do a pretty good job so
these are non quantum methods of doing
it and I think it's a very productive
metaphor for thinking about them a
different way of thinking about these is
using quantum information so i gave you
this intuition about monogamy how do we
make that quantitative and this was done
first in this really beautiful
breakthrough paper of brand aqua
standalone yard and then in this paper i
worked with fernando to get in some
cases the same bounds in some cases
stronger bounds i would say this paper
is really beautiful and uses all kinds
of wonderful technique from kind of
information theory and if you don't view
using a million different techniques
from quantum information theories an
advantage you should read this one which
is simpler and and and has a you know
fewer bells and whistles and gets you to
the proof faster whereas this one is is
more fun um so how do these monogamy
relations relations work here is sort of
this sketch of the proof so rho is k
extendable meaning we can think of it as
living on system a as well as k copies
of system p not literal copies it could
be sort of entangled across all of them
in some complicated away but the
marginal on a and any one of the bobs is
the same now suppose that m is in a
special form this i will not prove this
for general em but for an M that called
one way local operations and classical
communication and what that means is you
can perform the measurement m
by first measuring Bob and then
measuring Alice turns out you can go
from this to a general measurement by
losing a dimension factor but never mind
that let's just just accept that I'm
going to do this for a slightly
restricted case so suppose we do this
measurement and we get these outcomes x
y1 y2 through YK for measuring these
different systems these are now
classical outcome so we can just use
classical information theory to reason
about it then we have this very simple
and tropic argument look at the mutual
information between X and all of the
wise on the one hand it's at most law
again on the other hand we can use the
chain rule to writers the sum of K terms
so if you have my talk yesterday you saw
exactly the same inequality and there I
remembered to attribute this to
ragavendra in time today I forgot but
that's where we learned it from and
there K terms here that some of the most
log n so if K is big enough one of these
terms will be small and what does that
mean that means that X and one of the
wise are nearly independent conditioned
on the previous wise and so those
previous wives that's the classical
variable so that means that X and those
what that means that you have nearly a
separable state so you do a little bit
of algebra after this really not too
much and you find that if you optimize
over not separable states but k
acceptable states you get almost the
right answer and the error you get scale
is like some constant times the square
root of log n over K the significance of
using the information theory the
previous results got something to look
like n over K which from an algorithms
perspective is really no good because
then k has to go like end everything
exponential here you get something non
trivial when K is simply log in which
means you have the possibility of a
decent algorithm this sort of another
way of thinking about things which is
maybe more familiar from a rounding
perspective which is we repeatedly
measure system v sub I and then you have
a dilemma either the entropy of a does
not drop in which case the state of age
and change rain
and a in system B sub I or nearly
product which is what we wanted we want
something separable products even better
or if the entropy of a decreases then we
condition on bc by and move on and the
entropy can't keep on decreasing forever
it's gotta drop to zero eventually and
so either way you you make progress and
this is I think the familiar theme of
rounding algorithms that they're sort of
there's sort of this dilemma that the
that the bad instance has to face okay
so let me um so how well does this work
you know how what kind of algorithms do
we get so we do get um I think I'll try
and go through so quickly we do get this
this bound here with a pretty small
error term the measurement that we have
the corresponding to 24 norm is indeed
of the right form it's one LS you see or
rather it's proportional to a 1l FCC
measurement there's some overall overall
scaling factor and the problem is in
this approximation what this gets x is
the norm of the matrix m I you know
technically yeah i only get into the
details too much but the point is that
there are different norms and the one
that you get is the operator norm which
could be much bigger than thing that
you're approximating what we really
wanted with a multiplicative
approximation and and this simply does
not give that to us so um yeah um boy
there's some different definitive this
is so oh yeah I shouldn't have used the
word shouldn't've use the word definity
I definitely definitely needs a closely
related set of that what it often means
is that if you have a symmetric state on
end systems can you take a subset
visible yeah then those look like a
mixture of tens of powers of iid things
oh this is
extension of the classically yeah that's
right effort so anyway this again things
don't quite fit and you get something
actually this actually recreate the
previous selves exponential time bound
that we that we knew I think in a much
more complicated way I would not call
this a nice way way to prove it but this
show with your getting something non
trivial but it's it's not quite quite
good enough and it I think raises new
questions about how to improve things
which are I think are different than the
previous directions we were looking at
but again I don't want to claim that we
r epsilon away from solving it's just
that it's uh give us new directions to
look in solving it um I've talked about
one type of SVP in quantum information
and they want to back up briefly and
talk about other ways at st p's arise in
quantum information as well so they want
to talk about is you want to press my
except and you do this k extendable
relaxation there's another thing people
do call the adt i just stopped and
define it but it's a slight extension of
this as well symmetry not only between
the parties but between rows and columns
there's some other s dps as well one
that I I mentioned yesterday is if you
want to find the ground state energy of
a Hamiltonian and q-tips then your
relaxation is to express an opinion
about all k local observables meaning
its equivalent to expressing expanding
about all density matrices of subsets of
K system k cubits and they should have
this pot this semi definite property
this PSD property and this is a
different SVP which is useful for
quantum information it appears in
comparable to the first one and I don't
know of any relation in either direction
and but there I think it also has a
number of nice things and I I could have
spoken for a while about this one as
well there's a third one as well which I
would call the the non-commutative sum
of squares hence the cartoon to the the
non commuters sum of squares hierarchy
and this applies to a different goal
which is multiplayer games which you
heard people speak about
yesterday like drama and we have a
multiplayer game than what the players
are optimizing over is both the state
and their measurement operators and what
you express an opinion about is all
products of K measurement operators of
the two parties and again the opinion is
about the real expectation value and so
again you have polynomials or monomials
but now they're non-commutative and so
you have to keep track of perhaps all
different orderings of the operators and
express a different opinion about all of
those it still blows up exponentially
with K but faster and maybe you impose
some conditions like if they're two
parties then their operators should
commute with each other but of course
there's certainly some operators that
don't commute and the proof that this
works is called the non commuters
positive Stalin sighs there's a sense in
which is a generalization of number two
but we I would say we know very little
about this thing we know it converges we
have no idea how quickly we've no bounds
at all how quickly and we really like to
know more about these so what I told
about today was it look lad but the
first one but I think there's a lot of
nice connections of SD ps2 quantum
information and a lot of room to explore
oh and the questions are what are the
relations between these and what are
tools for analyzing them we really don't
know no we really don't know so much so
IBM thought by saying that it's
important about the right vocabulary
like Shannon did so we've developed a
little bit of vocabulary the sum of
squares proofs is a sort of vocabulary
using entropy for these things quantum
entry is some developing vocabulary but
of course are they the right terms are
the even on their way to the right terms
I don't know a more concrete question of
course we want to solve all the big
classic open problems computer science
and finally we have these ftp that
presentable last slide be nice to relate
them to each other and to analyze number
two and number three which we really
don't know as much as we do about number
one ok thanks for your attention and my
last far side cartoon tells you that
it's time for a coffee
you